they're speaking of liberal arts now
it's a film that stars yourself and also
Elizabeth Olsen and it as your love
interest in there now in the film she's
a particular fan of a book called
Twilight and maturity isn't she we don't
say the name of the book it could be any
vampire book I can't believe you thought
it was that book she loves it your
character Jessie doesn't quite share
feelings where do you stand on the gray
Twilight debate well I guess I can say
that I haven't really read it and I
don't you know I'm actually they have a
big argument about that book and I think
she wins that argument you know it's it
it's kind of an argument about them why
one why one reads do we read to be
entertained or do we read to be kind of
enriched and I think that that's a
really interesting debate among among
people who create things you know I mean
I'm I'm most interested in things that
are like are good for you but are also
kind of page-turners you know I don't
think like she says she read Chaucer and
she hated it and he says you're not
supposed to like it and she says then
why read it you know it's and I think
they have a really interesting
discussion about that but I think that
honestly anything you know there's kind
of this explosion of young adult books
that are all these adults are reading
there's debates about whether that's
good I think any time people are reading
books on actual printed pages I think
that this is good because you know I
remember when I was a kid I used to read
all those se Hinton books like The
Outsiders and Rumble fish and texts and
all that and I I think they're good
books but III it got me in love with
reading just sitting down with a book
and and you know having a story told to
you so I if people want to read those
books but but hopefully it'll bring them
to other reading experiences not just
those I don't understand why everyone's
obsessed with vampires that's just me
but I'm they don't interest me as a
there are other monsters that I'm more
taken with I don't know how much having
Elizabeth risa involved in the film
there yeah yeah that's cool that you
caught that cuz that's I think a really
good in joke of the movie because she's
in the Twilight movies I love Liz I've
known her since we were at I was at NYU
when she was at Julliard so I've known
her for years and we've been friends and
I've always wanted to work with
and I had this role and I just had this
hunch that she'd be great and and my
hunch paid off because I think she's so
she's so great and she loves all the
Twilight stuff she'd get such a kick out
of it to ask you about the setting for
the film could set it's a college and
her high that's pretty special for you
and your family as well isn't it tell us
a little bit about that it's a school
called Kenyon College it was founded in
I think 1824 and my father went there
and I did not want to go to the same
school my father went to but something
very strongly called me there and and it
wasn't it wasn't really family as much
as I just felt when I got on the campus
that it felt like my school somehow and
my younger sister ended up going there
also so it's a family kind of tradition
at this point and it's a really it's
just a great school there's the Kenyon
review is a famous literary magazine
that came out of there it still being
still publishes John Crowe ransom and
Robert Lowell these Yale doctor went
there famous novelist Paul Newman went
there Allison Janney went there who's an
actress in my movie so it was great to
then and we shot the movie there and
they welcomed us back with open arms and
didn't censor anything from the script
so I think they were really keen on
having us there was great and finally in
the movie as well they'd be played by
Elizabeth Olsen makes you a mixtape of
classical music a mix CD when was the
last time you made a mix tape for
someone or someone made one for you I
make them all the time I make a few for
the cast every year on my TV show that's
like that's like a thing I've done since
the beginning I've slowed down a bit and
they've been on me about that because
they like them and I yeah I do that with
some regularity I mean I even and a lot
of people who've seen the movie want the
music and there's not a soundtrack yet
obviously so I've been burning a couple
of those CDs for people because I think
it's a lot of that music it's some of
its well-known classical music
instruments less well-known and a lot of
people get really hooked by it and and
that's a thrill for me because I think
for other for people to have this
experience that Jessi's having which is
you know being awakened to this whole
new world through music and and I hope I
hope lots of people discover I I've been
the last few years for me has been
really exciting
discovering a lot of classical music so
I'm happy to bring it to people and you
mentioned the show there very quickly
which do you think your character Ted
would be taken by by zoobi well yeah but
who wouldn't be I mean he'd screw it up
in his spectacular fashion I'm sure
or he'd well he's been hasn't even
teaching architecture yes I think that's
right and it seems like he's been pretty
decent around the students thank you
very much Joe
okay good to talk to you
you